this is a fox news alert we have just
heard from the ceo of twitter
jack dorsey he tweeted this quote our
communication
around our actions on the new york post
article was not great
and blocking url sharing via tweet or dm
with zero context as to why we're
blocking
unacceptable huh
writes like a child manages the company
like one too
by the way the biden campaign is able to
call the story quote discredited
because big tech is trying to discredit
it
no reporter has taken a look at the
story and concluded oh sure this is a
russian fabrication
putin did this that's ridiculous so the
biden campaign is using
big tech as a pretext
for not responding and big tech of
course is trying to prevent you from
reading it at all
where does this go from here if biden is
elected you think
you really think that the big tech
companies are going to stop doing the
bidding of their masters in washington
not a chance you think big tech is going
to suddenly think oh you're allowed to
think for yourself
no last night in the show we questioned
whether masks are really effective at
the transmission of the chronovirus for
example
and as we did that we cited data
directly from the cdc
we pulled it off their website as well
as other scientific sources
science magazine for example one study
found that more than 70 percent of
patients who contracted the chronovirus
said they had
always worn a mask another 14 said they
usually did
we told you that last night we posted
that segment on facebook
today we learned that facebook is
calling our reporting quote partly false
we quoted the cdc they restricted the
distribution of the post to prevent
people from seeing it
again we can't say this enough the data
that we put on television last night
were from the centers for disease
control we used their numbers we didn't
make them up
but facebook censored it where's this
going exactly